there are no southern conservative
Democrats anymore there are no liberal
Republicans anymore yeah and is
everybody happy I don't think so
[Music]
hi George thanks for being here
delighted to talk to you about the
conservative sensibility which is just
out and you should know listeners should
know viewers should know that this will
be repurposed for my podcast the remnant
remnant of what well remember Albert J
nock
of course yes Samaras of his superfluous
man that's right and my enemy of the
state and he wrote a wonderful essay for
the Atlantic magazine and I believe 1936
called Isaiah's job and it's one of the
best essays in the history of sort of
conservatism liberalism libertarianism
in which he basically tells people don't
worry about trying to persuade the
masses all you can do is speak to the
remnant of those who hold on to correct
thinking I think as I want to say Walter
Benjamin paraphrased it and when I don't
know if you've noticed but when things
started to go a little wobbly among the
Republican Party and can the
conservative movement I return to my
love Albert a knock I'm a huge fan of
and I called the few of us left who
haven't had hadn't taken the crazy pills
the remnant and it became the perfect
name for my podcast there's good and so
in some ways you were the titular deity
of the remnant because you actually at a
moment where almost everybody else is
zagging towards some version of
nationalism or collectivism or Catholic
integral ISM which is the new hot thing
or as our friend Matt Kaneda teary
cently put it post liberal conservatism
you are zigging the other direction
towards actual classical liberalism and
liberalism rightly rightly understood so
your book is called
the conservative sensibility and why
don't you I talk to you with some length
about your book on c-span we will put a
link up to that
in the shownotes but why don't you for
the sake of listeners who hardly didn't
tune into that on a weekend night sort
of make your basic case I'm sure you
haven't done that yet on the book door
well I have noticed and I think lots of
Americans have noticed that things
aren't going well the prestige of
government has fallen as the pretenses
of government have arisen I thought it
was time for among other things an
exercise in intellectual archeology to
excavate the foundations of the Republic
and I thought of this as a Princeton PhD
in terms of an argument between two
Princetonian x' james madison of the
great class of 1771 and tommy as he was
known at Princeton Thomas Woodrow Wilson
of the class of 1879 Wilson being the
first president to criticize the
American Founding which meant
criticizing the constitutional
architecture that Madison erected in
response to the founders belief in the
natural rights which precede government
Wilson rejected this with remarkable
forthrightness and it turns out was a
remarkable success as he and subsequent
progressives have made hash of the
separation of powers with the
predictable consequence of an
emancipated president so in the longtime
listeners of this podcast know I
consider myself one of the nation's
foremost despisers of Woodrow Wilson so
this is an easy
get in line and as I said on the sea
spending a conversation I in some ways
my only criticism of your criticism
Wilson is it doesn't quite go far enough
you don't you don't get deep into the
political prisoners or the attacking the
hyphenated Americans or the war on the
German language but it's a good start
and but part of a part of your argument
which I share entirely is that what
Wilson did was he represented the
zeitgeist the intellectual zeitgeist of
the time which was besotted with
Bismark in darwin right and so part of
his critique of the original of the
foundering was that it was to Newtonian
Newtonian and it needed to become
Darwinian adapt to the times now part of
your argument which again I agree with
is that we've never quite that we've
never quite gotten over this notion
that's what the living Constitution
basically comes from how are we ever
going to get rid of it change change
public opinion at the end of the day
even Supreme Court justices are
nominated by elected people and
confirmed by elected people and so if
you understand that public opinion is
shiftable and you get busy trying to
shift it I agree with that entirely
persuasion is not it's not the ideal
tool but it's the only one we've got
exactly a part of part of your argument
which is a little radical to some years
believe it's in Chapter four is
persuading judges to use the power their
powers to not give a damn about public
opinion inside on liberalism or on
Liberty why don't you sort of explain
that for a second well there comes a
point at which judicial deference to
Democratic legislators is dereliction of
duty the duty to superintend the
excesses of democracy for years
conservatives upset by the freewheeling
rights manufacturers of the Warren Court
said what we really need is more
deference they were picking up the
conservative line that's celebrated
Oliver Wendell Holmes and others who
said Holmes famously if the people want
to go to hell I will help them it's my
job
meaning that the excesses of democracy
or what democracy is all about and he
could care less I believe that there is
a higher obligation than to the
majoritarian ethos of the times it is to
the Constitution and the so called
counter majoritarian difficulty which
was the phrase put into our vocabulary
by a great man Alexander Bickel of the
air law school who was a tutor a friend
of colleague of
Robert Bork he said that the Supreme
Court and judicial review is an
anomalous institution in a majoritarian
society and inherently problematic I
just don't think that's true
for several reasons first most of what
modern government does has nothing to do
with majorities and everything to do
with compact small intense educated
articulate confident and well lawyer
defections and therefore well the
majoritarian institutions responsive to
these factions does something peculiar
offensive to the rights of the citizen
me it's the courts job to swat it down
that's all
the Constitution after all is a tapestry
of particularly the Bill of Rights of
prohibitions on what majorities can do
you want an established church sorry you
can't have it you want restrictions on
free exercise of religion
can't have that either even if a
majority wants unreasonable searches and
seizures can't do it
you mentioned you can't have an
established Church there were states
that had established churches didn't do
do you think states could go back to
having established churches I do not I'm
what Scalia called himself a
faint-hearted originalist but to me the
original ISM first breaks on the Eighth
Amendment
there should be no cruel and unusual
punishments the cruel and unusual
punishments that were being inflicted in
Philadelphia in the summer of 1787 would
make Scalia and me and everyone else
Blanche so what you try and figure out
is what they what the Eighth Amendment
tried to do was put the country on
record against cruelty right and I'm
sorry to say that or a Warren got it
right there are evolving standards of
decency that marked the evolution of a
maturing society and you have to take
that into account same is true with
religion a big part of your argument is
that I think you stated forthrightly in
the introduction is that the task of
paraphrasing the task of American
conservatism is to conserve the founding
and the principles that creates
I'm very sympathetic to that and I think
as a practical matter the job of the
conservative goes to office to do
conservative things packs his lunch and
all the rest that a big chunk of his job
boils down to that but one of my sort of
philosophical problems this is very much
like a very much a Claremont Review of
Books position certainly prior to the
current occupant of the White House
which is that the American Founding is
the fundament of conservative
fundamentalist yes what's wrong with
saying Western civilization is the
fundament of America is the backdrop
here's my problem is I I I'm against
fundaments reducing all of conservatism
as a philosophical matter to the
founding leaves out all sorts of other
strains of intellectual Vaught cultural
norms that are also extremely important
why say this is what conservatism is
this is what American conservatism is
and the adjective does a lot of work in
and modifying that noun we're not blood
and soil thrown an alter tribal
conservatism in the European strain that
was evolved to defend existing
hierarchies and orders and institutions
we're semi Burkean in that and Burke had
a lively appreciation of what Hayek came
to call the spontaneous order of an
evolving natural society we go a step
farther however in saying that we want
to reconcile people to the openness the
exhilaration of an open society
obviously the United States owes an
enormous debt to various strands of
Western civilization particularly the
English enlightenment but we're better
at it that's why America where there is
something sublime about the United
States attempt to have a continental
Republic
till the Americans came along and
Madison revolutionized democratic theory
there was agreement among the few people
who thought democracy was possible that
it if possible it had to be in a small
face-to-face society
Madison said that's exactly wrong a
small face to face society is apt to be
homogeneous and therefore have a stable
and potentially tyrannical majority to
the peril of minorities therefore he
said have a Continental in extensive
Republic in which government protects
the different and unequal capacities of
acquiring property which guarantees is
saving multiplicity affections which
means stable shifting majorities that
are not a threat to minorities an
ecosystem yes he had a sociology of
political virtue and that was it so
you've been busy on a book tour so
you're probably not wading deep into the
weeds on the current obsessions
pointy-headed conservatives of different
types right this moment and actually
you've always kind of stayed somewhat
isolated from a lot of this stuff which
I want to talk about a little bit but
the last three weeks there has emerged
what some of us are calling the French
Wars my my very close friend and former
colleague in National Review David
French was the target of what I would
consider to be a generally unfair attack
by another friend of mine we're not
nearly as close sourabh Amari of the
block New York Post and it turns out
that while no one was paying attention
the old el brent bozell senior argument
that we actually need to live in
basically a theocratic society where the
state imposes a notion of the high are
good or the highest good has erupted out
of nowhere and David and what in some so
one of the reasons why I want bring this
up is that I think David is a is a truly
unfair target of all of this ire and you
are actually a far more fitting one yes
but I think a lot of people are afraid
to attack you
and so they go after poor David but
David is a evangelical Christian he's
been fighting for Christian you know for
religious liberty and campus free speech
stuff for four decades and his great sin
is that he refuses to say that Donald
Trump is a man of good character and all
of these kinds of things well he's also
accused I gather of having good manners
that's right
he's polite yes oh my god and there is
this theory that what is required is to
in some way imbibe the pugnacious nosov
Donald Trump and that will lead to
victory of some kind have you waited
into any of this no I've watched from
afar and I've seen this eruption there
this is an outgrowth of the flight 93
election syndrome which is that the end
is nigh and less people listen to people
like us
right it's a way of pumping up the
grandeur and magnificence and importance
of people who say we stand at Armageddon
and things have never been worse
but they might get worse tomorrow but
unless radical things are done and
people who disagree with you must shut
up for we're at existential crisis
exactly the existential crisis but the
self dramatizing things aren't that bad
yeah I mean I'm not happy you know no
one right no one writes political
philosophy as their content right
because you're irritated about something
or anxious or afraid or something but I
just think this hysteria is to be
ignored I quote you in one of my
previous books there's a story you tell
about how when you first got your
syndicated column you called George that
William F Buckley
how the heck am I going to write two
columns a week what was his advice to
you he said the world irritates me three
times a week he wrote three times a week
so we rally wrote a sermon and in the
world turns out it's true the world
irritates or amuses or piques my
curiosity 100 times a year I've never
had a day when I didn't have three or
four things I wanted to write about
yeah but nevertheless right you carry on
I do I've got in my pocket so one of the
things I think is sort of fascinating
this moment is the conservative
consensus as the first things crowd
calls it is basic they claim is
shattered which i think is a little bit
of wish casting but maybe they're right
what was it well basically it was fusion
ISM Frank Myers notion of balancing
notions the fusion ISM shorthand is a a
virtuous a free society can only be
virtuous if virtue is freely chosen
virtue imposed is not virtuous and you
create people that will lead that will
lead themselves to tyranny if you think
that you can impose virtue from above
and the tucker carlson longtime friend
of mine
you're impose oniy Patrick Danine the
guys at first things Saurabh they've
basically to one extent or another it's
difficult to generalise have turned
their back for I'm barely on this notion
that of free markets and they claim that
as Tucker Carlson put it that the
Washington Consensus is that is is
entirely libertarian in that Washington
is run that is the same response he
lived in this well but there's a shell
game going on because what they do is
they define sort of the Lockean liberal
order as essentially libertarian because
the individual autonomy of free choice
is a libertarian notion and so their
form out you know supporting free
markets and whatnot amounts to
libertarianism which i think is a there
are many stolen bases in that that
journey there and on free markets
amounts to what imminence heisting the
eschaton I don't know I don't know war
on ISM socialism whatever we go yeah
well you know so Tucker the other night
came out in lavish praise on Elizabeth
Warren he said he should have because he
is a working-class socialist he's not
exactly working-class I don't know I
don't know how many of them he rubs
elbows with at the Metropolitan Club but
he likes he likes them from a distance
so you actually this is the gossip
portion of these things you started at
National Review and 71 73 73 as Frank
Meier was dying of cancer
do you know Frank Meyer at all I did I
went up to saw him and his wife at their
know Woodstock as I recall as I know
upstate met from the city and Hudson
Valley I didn't realize he was
telecommuting then but well he wasn't he
was sick and bill said you want to be a
columnist could you also do the back of
the book and I know nothing about it so
sure and that's how I got to know Frank
so Frank was those who don't know was a
literary editor yeah and especially the
managing editor released for a time of
the magazine what what was he like a man
of managed in by an Ernest was
earnestness with good will and not and
cheerfulness what was it like working at
National Review back in those days well
it was great in part because of
Priscilla Buckley Bill's sister who made
the trains run on time yeah she was just
terrific and bill was fun and bill was
again cheerful yeah and polite
impeccably polite yes French ISM that's
right premature friendship that's the
thing when people ask me what it was
like I was very lucky there's sort of a
post Buckley pre Buckley people who
worked at National Review in my time and
I was fortunate enough to get to know
Bill and when I first and I've been
saying this for years the first time I
was invited to his maison that -
whatever you call that on 73rd Street I
was terrified because I thought it was
going to be Chesterton quotes and Latin
puns all night well it turns out that
bill was if the debt if the definition
of good manners isn't necessarily what
fork to use but making people feel
respected and listened to but he's
arguably the best mannered person I'd
ever met in my life and the eye and so
it was interesting I was reading this
book about Bill rusher and who's the
longtime publisher and National Review
and the author was making this point
that one of the great advantages of
William F Buckley was that at a time
when everyone was the media was so
determined to make George Wallace seem
like the face of what right the right
was
Buckley comes along mannered erudite can
out debate Galbraith and all these kinds
of people and even though you were
annoying a good number of people at
National Review for calling for Spiro
Agnew to be dumped from the ticket and
always then all your Watergate columns
you were at the end of the day we were
considered a net asset because you were
one of the only younger people out there
who could do the similar stuff that that
Buckley was doing there's a close call
but in everything but you did not win a
lot of friends on the right back in
those days you were a harsh critic of
the Nixon administration which didn't
help me I left the Senate staff at the
end of 1972 to start a column with
National Review and Meg Greenfield the
then deputy editor of the Washington
Post editorial page that submitted
columns to us also so I did and they
decided to start a syndication to
Washington Post writers group in order
to syndicate David Broder but it's as
easy to syndicate to as once they said
we'll do we'll also somebody said we
have this great marketing idea
Agnew had been crashing around the
country saying there's Mao Mao in the
editorial pages so you're not enough for
conservator lady Bob's battery mobs of
negativism and all the rest and the Post
said fine we'll tell the editors here's
someone who on last support next time so
I become a columnist in January 73 at
about the time Judge Sirica imposes the
severe penalties probably excessive
penalties on James from accord and
others and the Watergate thing begins to
unravel so I called it as I saw it and I
thought there was where there's a lot of
smoke there's no smoke and I'm gonna and
I kept at this and at one point Nixon's
chief of staff Alexander Haig called me
in my home and said the boss really
likes your writing and maybe you'd like
to come over and get on board at the
White House and I said I am extremely
flattered but you should read my next
column before you extend this offer and
I never heard from them again
so over your long tenure as a columnist
and as a conservative and in sort of one
of the Mount Rushmore figureheads of
let's say post 65 conservatism you've
managed to do two things and one of the
things is not obvious is that is obvious
to a lot of people which is use
Ramanujan OTT go native and sort of
mellow or try how to put this mellows
the wrong word you didn't grow as Linda
greenhouse we put it as new respect
that's right it's profile increased you
still I remember I remember long time
ago the 90s I was here at AEI and you
wrote a scathing column about Dan
Rostenkowski and I remember Tom Mann
being just stunned that someone in your
elite position could remain as distant
from the sort of swamp stuff the other
part which I don't think a lot of people
understand is that you also kind of kept
at an arm's length a lot of the sort of
conservative industrial complex stuff as
well I mean you add your start briefly
it not started but you had your time at
national review but you were in some
ways sort of like The Reader's Digest
but apart you know yeah I don't mean
silly I mean you know apparently that's
temperamental Samuel Johnson described
himself as uncouple and I may be
unpleasant
so going back to the days of the Nixon
stuff were the arguments then on the
right such as you were part of them
earlier or meaningfully different than
the arguments we're having today about
Trump I think they were more civil and
they were more substantive and they
weren't as angry basically conservatives
knew what they were worried about first
of all the Soviet Union which we tend to
forget has gone away and organized a lot
of thinking arms control on all the rest
and then there was the question of
pandemic spending this was at a time
when it was still possible to believe
that Americans conservatives in public
office cared about pandemic deficits we
now know they don't anymore which
simplifies the argument saying so but it
was different if you had to diagnose the
maladies that explained that difference
where would you how would you do the
triage of your diagnosis there well
conservatives many conservatives have
succumbed to the temptation of power
scripture tells us to put not our faith
in Princes they put their faith in a
prince right
and when he's gone we'll pick another
Prince they are they have fully absorbed
the ethos of presidential government
presidential Society really I mean we
have no president has ever come close to
absorbing public attention and the
national consciousness if you will to
this one Roosevelt to sort of
revolutionized presidential rhetoric
with using that marvelous new invention
radio never came close never tried to
come to us how many fireside chats what
are you doing a year I don't even know
maybe seven right that's a that's a pre
five a.m. tweet storm by the current
person so the Conservatives have happily
been swept up in the maelstrom of
presidential IDUs but isn't part of that
a symptom of the Madisonian sociology
breaking down yes if you had healthy
institutions where people were had roots
there they might not look to Washington
for president to entertain them or to
give them meaning whether it's Barack
Obama or Donald Trump and if members of
Congress did not think of themselves as
team players either on the president's
team or on the visiting team playing the
president's team you would have
something has something like the
Madisonian institutional equilibrium but
that's gone so doesn't that raise the
prospect then as much as I agree with
you
persuasion is very much important that a
huge amount of our problems lie way
upstream of Washington and which I
understand the yeah some of this is in
your book that none of the problems that
we see today whether or not you think
Donald Trump is a problem with Barack
Obama is a problem or the the life of
Julia ethos is a problem if you had
healthier families and healthier
communities and healthier institutions
like organized religion and whatnot
people would not be looking to
Washington to find meaning in their
lives in the first place I think that's
right in the search for meaning and
collective action and politics is the
source of ruined the 20th century
communism fascism all the rest the mass
movements need a mass and it needs the
massification of people and what's scary
is when people embrace that consciously
and enthusiastically there's that essay
from Wilson about leaders of men
exactly bind up libre well he gave it in
one of his I quoted it's an epigraph of
one of my chapters he says in the good
society people will be like bees and a
high of frame very strange aspiration
but I fit with his people have to calm
down about politics government is
important free markets are government
creations I got that government has lots
to do fill the potholes deliver the mail
I guess doesn't do that so much anymore
but do whatever it does that's plenty
zillion delivering meaning isn't one of
them so this brings me back to the
question I asked earlier about state
established churches I am as I get older
I've become at the federal level more
radically libertarian than I used to be
and at the local level I get vastly more
communitarian than I used to be what is
so wrong with you know first of all
bringing back the ninth Tenth Amendment
and all of that that would be nice
sending as much power down to the most
local level possible subsidiarity as the
catholics say right yes and and that
would but so here's the here's the
question the isn't part of the problem
we have it's not somewhat
tyranny of majorities its tyranny of
national majorities I'm much less
concerned about the quote unquote
tyranny of majorities at a local level
that's exactly where Madison worried
about the tyrannies which is why he
wanted the extensive Republic he said in
a local small area where the so that the
anti-federalists are celebrated you are
much more apt to have stable tyrannical
majorities we did indeed we had localism
in Jim Crow laws sure sure no they
respect that they reflected the majority
opinion in Greenville Mississippi and in
Gadsden Alabama and it took it took a
national decision not to respect local
majorities and it was a virtuous
decision I agree with that entirely
they were democratic tyrannies and they
needed to be smashed but they also the
issue of slavery rises to a first-order
question about natural rights that
dignity of the individual and all these
kinds of things
banning rap music or having curfews or
or prohibition on alcohol in some small
town seems to me that's an area where
the federal government should be
entirely silent other than to say you
can't do it at the local level that's
where you and I differ okay I'm not a
prohibitionist or an anti-prohibitionist
I do remember getting a jolt toward
libertarianism when I was driving with
one of my children from Washington to
Kew Island South Carolina where I have a
home and I stopped for the night in
Florence South Carolina on Sunday night
looking for my evening martini and found
that the local ayatollahs and said that
was not going to happen and I said this
is insufferable and got more libertarian
as a result of that but banning rap
music on what grounds exercising what
power of government want to purify the
culture to censor offensive speech I
don't want to go down there yeah no
that's fair I should say I'm not in
favor of banning any music or any of
that kind of stuff and in fact my
positions on the local level will be
fairly
returning about many of these things but
being able to heavily regulate what you
can do in the public square in a local
area seems to me here's my diagnosed my
diagnosis of the problem is that when
you send all this power to Washington or
the federal regime or whatever you want
to call it it is inevitable that people
at a local level far away are gonna feel
like unseen forces whether you call them
the deep state or the administrative
state or the globalists or whatever you
want to call them that they feel
powerless and that powerlessness is the
classic kindling for populist movements
mhm and if you send power back down a
little most local level possible the
powers that be suddenly have names and
the know who to fire and you know to how
to hold them accountable and that also
means that if they have that power
they're gonna exercise it in ways I mean
laboratories of democracy is a lote with
a loaded phrase Brandeis had an agenda
there but letting people having the
transcendental imagination which is a
phrase you've used in a few columns to
make this a more interesting country to
drive across yes we're communities
because as Antonin Scalia was the first
to point out to me federalism is the
best system ever conceived of for
maximizing human happiness because it
lets the most people live the way they
want to live and then they can vote with
their feet that's right like get a
martini in Nakia whatever this other
place was yes where you do what Bill
Buckley did and always travel with your
own alcohol no III agree with that if
power is to be exercised it ought to be
exercised as much as possible at the
local level the question is how much
power should be exercised collectively
through government okay that's fair and
and that's a Prudential question yeah I
agree with that
but you know that when I talk to college
kids about this you know you have to say
you have to open up by saying slavery
was bad they were right to crush that
Jim Crow is that I also like to point
out though that Jim Crow was wasn't
capitalism
it was statism it was the kind of Public
Choice factions that you despised
conspiring against the public good to
rig the system to constrain
local labor markets and black people
couldn't move right and so once I
concede or explain all that I then say
now do you really think that your local
microbrewery
it means the okay from someone in
Washington do you think like the Oregon
state health officials are okay with
this microbrews e poi poisoning you yeah
you know or why can't you get you know
unpasteurized cheese that tastes like
death without Washington's approval and
that part they kind of get is no young
people today hate the homogeneous Asian
of America that they think comes from
capitalism some of it comes from
capitalism but some of them comes from
an overweening federal government that
runs everything right anyway that's my
well I do this often on this podcast as
rant about this you are not in fact
pessimistic about the future or about
America well my book is a summons to
intelligent pessimism okay not fatalism
pessimism in the sense that there are so
many ways things can go wrong in so many
ways that things have gone wrong in the
human story that it is wise to be alert
to the looming possibility that it will
happen again
and we know it the problems with
democracy can be we know some of them
and they're unimaginative in so be alert
that's all be wary it's like living in
the city there are wonderful pleasures
living in the city but there also
requires a certain urban wariness about
certain neighborhoods and certain
behaviors and you'd learn to live that
way
it's true of democracy this is a
fantastic segue to the story I want to
tell which I don't think you know of so
the first time we met I was an earnest
college student at a place called
Goucher College and I was part of the
first year of ethics of co-education so
I was up in Baltimore up in Baltimore
I'm not quite the Rosa Parks agenda
integration but I did my bit and and you
came to give a speech and I was invited
to the President's House for a pre
meeting among student leaders and
faculty and whatnot
and we were talking and uh and I
begrudge you not at all for not
remembering this and how he now having
done so many campus visits there are
countless people come up to message you
don't remember meeting me and there
right and this was also thirty something
years ago and and we were talking and I
explained to you that Victor Lasky was
my brother's Godfather and when my
father's best friends and for the
listeners who don't know Victor Lasky
was a muckraking right winger of a sword
but an interesting fellow and and my
parents knew William Safire I don't
think I told you that the first time I
met Pat Buchanan was at my bris which
was an interesting way to meet that and
I was my friend Rob long says that might
explain some of his attitudes towards of
the Jews and so at some point and was
all going great and then at some point
we were talking about New York City
where I'm from and this was probably the
height of the crime wave certainly of
the murder with and I mentioned that
there were times in high school where me
and my friends would my friends and I
would walk through Central Park at night
and a look of disdain came over your
face and you said well I have something
along the lines of one you're an idiot
and the conversation sort of ended there
and you were actually correct that's
fine I'm not again I don't begrudge you
either and so fast forward about five
years you were in your term limits phase
you still on term moment yes okay they
kept a two on IR I think those come out
for term limits and we'll come back to
that a second so I was a young policy
Nome at the American Enterprise
Institute very earnest and you were
giving your Bradley lecture about about
terminus and I said during the Q&A I
said what a lot of the problems that
you're addressing be solved if we just
went back to the founders vision about
how big congressional districts should
be and that we should actually have a
congresses about five or six thousand
people and the sovereign contempt with
which you greeted this question enraged
and and people laughed at me you won
this exchange and I heed myself to my
personal Monastery of my apartment on
16th Street and pounded the typewriter
like Snoopy coming up with this
irrefutable argument about all this and
I worked on this and I worked on this
and trimmed it down worked on it some
more and I ended up as happenstance
would have it it was the first op-ed I
ever submitted for publication I sent it
to the Wall Street Journal and they
accepted it uh-huh
and they sat on it for a few months and
then the day after the election in 1992
I think it was yeah it was it was Newt
Gingrich Bill Bennett and Jonah Goldberg
and I was making the argument for
expanding the size of the House
Representative I did in a fun mirthful
kind of way but when you talk about how
annoyance is your muse yeah if you had
not humiliated me so I am not sure I
ever would have gotten this bug so I owe
it all that's why I did it
as Franklin Roosevelt used to say after
some fortuity had rescued him he's out
planted that but I thought you should
know that I'm glad I know yeah so what
do you say to the problem back to term
limits what do you say the problem of if
you have term limits all you're doing is
handing power over to the sort of
permanent bureaucracy of Washington even
more there's not that much more for it
to get they've already done this without
term limits
it is a real danger every reform has
problems the question is what's worst
right and I have come to the conclusion
I came in wrote a book in 94 I think
restoration
Congress term limits and the recovery of
deliberative democracy I understand the
problem of the permanent government I
understand the problem of the lobbyists
community I understand the problem of
draining institutional memory from from
the Senate in the house got it I just
think that there's no safety in politics
there's an
you're gonna you're gonna cause problems
with term limits I just think on balance
fewer and more tractable problems one of
the main drivers of our the problem with
our politics is that despite the fact we
live in the most one of those partisan
times and history our parties have never
been weaker yes and couldn't some of the
problems that you're you identifying
again I think you identify correctly be
solved if we actually let the parties be
stronger and having an institutional
interest in protecting their own brand
and having a time horizon beyond the
next election yes and one way to do that
is to abolish all campaign finance laws
no all of which I think are
constitutionally problematic at best let
the money go pour back in right reduce
the role of candidates as freebooting
entrepreneurs raising their own capital
to invest in themselves but the parties
distribute money the way they used to
very good idea and another one would be
I would argue if I agree with you
entirely what Mitch McConnell said we're
not getting money out of politics we're
just getting the party's out of politics
and I think he was proven right but one
in another or would another part of the
solution be to have the parties give up
on the primary system back to the
smoke-filled room and the Blackstone
Hotel in Chicago pretty much yeah but
who's gonna play mayor Daly and who's
gonna play boss Hague and who's gonna
play boss crumped and all those people
you can just have a mixed regime look at
the lane Kmart makes this point that
America is the only advanced
industrialized democracy where the
parties have completely abdicated the
power to pick their own nominees yes and
which is the most important thing they
do it is what they do there was
everything and I think that has been
disastrous you know Yuval Levin makes
this point often that you know there are
one of those signature problems with our
culture is that his properly understood
what an institution does is a forges
character it forges you to give up your
sort of Russo nyan novel savage and bend
yourself to the needs of an institution
Marines being the best example of it
though and you've all identifies the
problem in our culture is that we no
longer see or too many people know of no
longer see institutions as something
that they surrender to they see them as
platforms to perform on and if you look
at the story of Donald Trump
and and Bernie Sanders they did not see
the Republican Party as an institution
they should bend to they saw it as
something at best to perform on if not
to entertain by gladiatorial e
disemboweling it for a moment
consumption and so the very least you
could bring back the notion of a robust
system of delegates that are actually
left up to state parties or something
like that you know of course the
Democrats have just completed the last
year's coin o Fraser remnant of the old
way of doing things by further reducing
I don't know if they've entirely
extinguished the super-delegates who
were supposed to be the adults in the
room we said look it's our business we
are elected officials it's our business
to win elections here's how you do it
but that's a lost argument yeah but as
you say our task at hand is persuasion
okay and it seems to me that I would
have an easier time persuading party
hacks that they should have more power
then I should be able to persuade the
masses that they should pick up their
own damn crab or whatever and so I think
there isn't a an elite play here where
you can actually persuade institutions
that they deserve to have more power and
that might be easier job than than the
rest I just because what we're heading
into is a system that was not designed
to be a parliamentary system behaving
like a parliamentary system yeah
well 60 years ago the political
scientists in America said if only the
parties would sort themselves out on
ideological grounds we'd have a rational
politics like Europe we've done that and
is everybody happy not exactly right
when I came to Washington to work on
this Republican senators staff 1970 the
Senate was run by Eastland of
Mississippi Stennis of Mississippi
Richard Russell from winter Georgia
McClellan from Arkansas Talmadge from
Georgia it's entirely Southern Democrats
not entirely close enough
there are no southern conservative
Democrats anymore there are no liberal
Republicans anymore and is everybody
happy I don't think so
so buy gold well George is still very
weird to call you George you're mr. will
and my eyes but thank you very much for
doing this hey everyone
that's the end of our discussion with
George Will thanks for watching if you
enjoyed what you saw remember to like
the video or leave us a comment and be
sure to check out the rest of our videos
and research from AEI